i just want to have a normal
conversation with natalie
to see where we stand
it doesn't seem like she wants to have
that conversation so what can i do
what's up you punkasaurus
what are you doing um
i just need to process some uh yeah
where's natalie right now she's at
giuliana's
why is she a julie honest i i want to
know the same
same answer we had that fight last night
you know
and so you guys have a fight every night
you know why
she does it on purpose so she has an
excuse to leave
yeah i just don't get where natalie
turns around and she does the most
evil stuff and it is
evil yeah you know
well when she does be mean like that
that just tells me
the whole thing about getting over here
to america
it didn't matter if it was you son
or some other man
she doesn't even like you
that's how i look at it
she's a snake in the grass
she's a scammer period
you know i can't talk about her like
that
i mean i don't know she i believe the
minute she gets her work visa
and the minute she gets her green card
she's gonna be gone
i guess time will tell on that one won't
it you know well probably won't be long
right
i don't know don't know
i can divorce her ass and she'd go back
you